the year 2008 the problem people aren't
switching to dollar coins even though
they're heavier the solution allow the
general public to purchase the coins at
face value directly from the US Mint and
cover the cost of shipping sounds like a
great idea with the best of intentions
what could possibly go wrong it turns
out people like free stuff and some
credit cards offer rewards customers
realize they could charge thousands of
dollars worth of coins and then
immediately pay off the balance with
those very same coins earning loads of
free airline miles eventually the mint
caught on changed their rules and block
suspicious buyers from further purchases
but not before many had jacked up their
Reward Points banking free trips around
the world one frequent flyer is even
said to have bought 800 Grand in coins
helping him earn lifetime Platinum Elite
status on American Airlines now that's a
coin trick